well that's one way to say goodbye to
your friends
[Music]
patreon sponsored review for this one
and this is a film that I had heard of
the name of knew almost nothing about
and have now seen it's called the man
from Earth now it's funny the folks who
have been so far sponsoring the patreon
reviews have not requested me to do
additional research on the films that
that have been commissioned but I find
myself doing it anyway because the the
projects are kind of interesting so this
was an incredibly low budget film I
believe it had a $200,000 budget which
is nothing that's that's not even the
catering budget on a on a mid-sized
movie so this and I'll go spoiler free
for as long as I can I am gonna describe
the setup and premise and also I'm gonna
advise that if this intrigues you at all
don't watch the trailer it doesn't
really spoil a lot but it does sort of
indicate some of the directions of some
of the later half elements of the film
so I would advise against that but
anyway this is one of those movies that
is just a group of people sitting down
and talking that is the whole movie I
tried to think of some other examples
off the top of my head I I kept coming
back to my dinner with Andre which I
don't know if anybody even my age much
less younger has even heard of much less
seeing that movie I have for the record
pretty good actually
but you know it's it's single location
and just characters talking that's not
to say nothing happens but what happens
is all characters shifting in terms of
their stance on things the thoughts
their understanding their comfort levels
with everything that's going on that's
the story there's no action in it
there's no there's no sequence of events
it's just watching these characters play
out this evening so the starting premise
is we have basically we have a ton we
not a ton we have a collection of
college professors and one student and
one of them a guy named John he's
leaving and he hasn't really explained
why to any of the other folks that are
there I mean they've all gathered for
you know kind of a goodbye and a
send-off but you know he won't say why
he's leaving beyond just you know I do
this from time to time I think it's just
time I moved on and all kind of on a
whim he decides that he's going to tell
them but he claims to be the truth which
is that he has been alive since the
cro-magnon era of humanity he doesn't
get older and he's moving on because
it's been about 10 years and people are
starting to notice that he's not seeming
to get older so that's usually ask you
to move on somewhere else and then it's
just conversations going on between all
these characters sort of dismissing
processing considering the possibility
looking at the implications even if only
in a thought experiment kind of way
getting offended getting intrigued all
these different angles and opinions
based off that one starting premise and
that's the film so the the cast is
pretty good and this and it's it there's
like a couple of I know that person but
I don't know their name people the only
one whose name I actually knew was Tony
Todd but it's really it's it's
well-written in terms of having a
collection of characters that who's real
actions - not just the starting premise
but every stage of the conversation as
it continues is varied enough that it
keeps things moving forward he keeps
things from getting dull because all the
the various professors there have
different backgrounds there is a
sociologist there's a paleontologist
there is a art historian there's a
biologist there's a psychiatrist and
they're all sort of coming at what John
is saying from different angles in
addition to you know their actual
personalities and then you know other
beliefs that they have beyond their
academic pursuits that are coming into
play and everybody's balanced pretty
well I was surprised there's the
biologist who's uh because you also get
a taste of these guys personalities like
the biologist is you know the funny one
of the group you get that that's his
shtick and he knows that's his shtick
and he does it a lot but at the same
time it doesn't become grating because
that kind of thing can become grating
really quickly but he's he's balanced
really well and it there is just enough
of that genuine sort of him mulling all
this over in his head and he'll make a
joke but you can tell he's still kind of
latched in and and trying to dig out
what's going on and you know then you've
got somebody like the paleontologist who
is very obviously the cool professor you
know he's got his hair pulled back in a
ponytail he shows up on a motorcycle
it's kind of a tool and and you know you
see how all this stuff factors in now
this is not a very cinematic movie this
is one of those films that I watch and I
have a tendency to think to myself why
was this ever a film why wasn't this
just a play and I think I might be
slightly validated on that because
apparently the director about five years
after this film was made adapted it into
a play which is supposedly pretty good I
would imagine it is because it's it is
just as it is just so straightforward
that there's no read there's no
reason for this to be a movie instead of
a play and I don't mean that as a knock
it's good you know there was no reason
for you know 12 Angry Men to be done as
a film because it works absolutely as a
play I think that might be that film
might be a one that folks have actually
seen that I can make a comparison to
although it's not as as intense as that
story is but you know the there isn't a
lot that the camera adds there isn't a
sense of atmosphere brought by the
choice of angles by the framing but you
buy that the cameras just kind of there
and yeah and it's not distracting it's
not badly film but it's very it's very
pedestrian you know I and this is the
kind of thing in general that I think I
do prefer to see on the stage because I
tend to get into a into a headspace
where I'm digesting these sort of
character pieces a little bit better I
want it to play but it it was
interesting it was intriguing and I the
way and the pace that it all unfolded
worked really well because it's the sort
of thing that these sorts of things for
me often can start and like a hand like
I'm that's really interesting and then
half hour enema queue have burned
through all your ideas and yet we're
still here and I didn't feel that was
the case here and there's a lot of
really interesting responses especially
from John you know the the main
character in regards to how he answers
so many of the questions that get thrown
at him I'm gonna be getting a little bit
into spoilers in a minute I think
because the there were a couple of
points where it didn't lose me but I
started to disengage a little bit but
then will pull me back but then I
disengaged again and so to get into into
that I have to I I do have to get into
spoilers so if you enjoyed these sort of
talky I don't want to say philosophical
because that
implies a more distant thing because it
is much more about people and their
reactions and there is more motion to it
than I wouldn't want to call it a
philosophical film but it is just a it
is it is just a conversation you know
it's an hour hour forty conversation
that is what you are watching so if that
kind of thing can intrigue you and you
know you're into you know a little bit
of sci-fi or honestly it's almost
borderline magical realism in terms of
the the way the premise is handled give
a shot it's it's an interesting little
film so if you're still here getting in
spoilers in three two one
some of the specifics about what John
says he encountered and then later what
he did
specifically returns to the more
religious end of the conversation I've
it disengage from me and then some of
how that played out felt a little bit
clunky to me so when he mentioned having
met Buddha I kind of rolled my eyes at
that because I don't know that it's like
when people are really into the idea
that they have had past lives but they
always insist that they used to be
Cleopatra or Joan of Arc nobody ever
says I was a long succession of peasants
in the Middle Ages all of whom died at
twenty you know nobody ever says that
they have to make an association with
some some big name somebody famous and
and this had the ring of that like it's
not like you the idea of somebody having
been alive for thousands of thousands
thousands of years to have experience as
much as he did especially the way he
talks about it where like you know
they'll try and quiz him on specific
things and like you know where where
were you this exact date last year can
you tell me that why
you asking me where I was in 11:20 ad so
you know his way of approaching that is
all really intriguing in the first place
so to start basically name-dropping be
like oh yeah I hung out with Buddha it's
like oh it's unnecessary and it feels
like it's trying too hard now that does
end up factoring into what happens a
little bit later which is basically that
John claims to be Jesus kind of by
accident like he he met Buddha and he
took the teachings from Buddha and
readapted them and taught what he
thought was you know something that
would help people and then his teaching
is eventually being recorded by other
people and then rerecorded retranslated
etc etc became the Christ story and
again it is sort of it's almost the
story becoming too big for its own good
and then it also brings out some
elements that I don't like him one of
the characters because one of the
characters is you know she's not only a
professor but she is also it would
appear a fairly devout Christian and I
feel like that was handled really
ham-fisted Lee I don't know a lot about
the guy who wrote this
Jerome brics Lee I believe he I so I
don't know about him and I don't know if
this is the case but the way she's
written feels like what it feels like
how an atheist would would write a
person of faith you know it just has
that kind of caricature reaction to
things and it's really kind of the only
area where you get the heavy
caricaturing and and you know some of
these characters come across fairly
broad but they still feel like there's
depth and there's a little bit of nuance
to them because there's a little bit
more than what's on the surface and it
doesn't feel like the writer and or the
director really had a proper
understanding of how someone of faith
would react to what was
they just went with oh she's angry she's
gonna say it's sacrilege it's like whoa
she's also an academic and an
intellectual and like you're just
assuming the most knee-jerk reaction out
of her which is the least interesting
possible reaction she could have had and
I'm not saying like don't address how
this is potentially shaking her faith or
at least making her really uncomfortable
you can address that but the way in
which they did it just felt like the
low-hanging fruit way to do it and then
the very end also overreached a little
bit because we've got the we've got the
psychiatrist and actually what happens
towards the end with him coming to a
realization that John was telling the
truth and realizing that the two of them
have a history together and see that
should be dumb but honestly it felt like
it was played just right and turned into
a really sweet moment and then the guy
keeled over like from a heart attack or
something and that and I I rolled my
eyes at that
I just just flat I was like that mm-hmm
you overreached because honestly I it
almost felt like an overreach just at
the revelation but the the way the guy
reacted and responded in the sense of
confusion and anger and joy that he was
really good at bringing across it made a
really touching moment and then he's
just kind of he falls down I was like
what the hell so you know that that was
a little bit of a sour final note which
was unfortunate because like I said I do
like this piece I enjoyed these kinds of
character pieces again I'm more used to
and I'm sort of more at home seeing them
on a stage but I enjoy them because they
get they get me thinking about
characters about people about how they
interact how they talk and it's it's
stuff like this that will often send me
off you know come to my to my notebooks
to
you know scribbling out bits of dialogue
bits of ideas it's stuff like this that
usually ends up with me having written
something after having seen and digested
stuff like this so so I did like it and
I did appreciate it and I want to thank
my patreon sponsor for strong-arming me
into doing it so yeah and yeah as you
can guess it is actually possible on the
patreon page to contribute at a level
where you get to flat-out say something
that I have to review even if it's
something I wouldn't normally review
even if you deliberately are picking
something that you think I'm gonna hate
which hasn't happened yet I feel it's
coming though but honestly I I haven't
talked to Pacific another page in a
while even if you don't want to
contribute at that high level just being
even a minimum level support patron you
get to participate in exclusive polls to
help me decide things like what's the
next classic Doctor Who episode I'm
gonna review the next Big Finish episode
when I have competing ideas or like two
things that'd come out I don't know what
to release first I'll pull my patron so
I it is just at any level of support you
get to basically have more kind of
direct input onto the future direction
of this channel and you're helping make
it better in theory we'll see so the man
from Earth interesting little film so
that'll about wrap it up for me have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do such as like it subscribe I mentioned
the page around I won't mention it again
but links for that and a ton of other
stuff by me down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]